i had drew barrymore on recently and
every time she's on
i asked her about this point in her life
where she's 14 years old
and she's been emancipated she's had
problems with her family she's had
problems with her mother she was a you
know a troubled kid
and she gets out of rehab and she says
and then i went to live with david
crosby for months
here's what happened we knew her because
we were in recovery
at that time we were going to meetings
well probably three times a week and
uh totally sober she was in a facility
that was run by a friend
of ours and they said oh [ __ ] her
inserts is going to run out
we're going to have to kick her out and
she's not ready she needs a safe place
to go and it can't be with her parents
she came stayed with us for a while and
you know we took her to school in the
morning and
uh tried to be a good influence i think
we were kind
and and loving and
uh it felt good to do you know you try
to do stuff and you're not
sure how it's going to work out i think
that one worked out i think she became a
responsible human being and
is a nice person are there rules when uh
david crosby steps in and becomes your
father
you know what or is it kind of like hey
anything goes there's no bedtime
no it didn't work like that at all i go
through all these different phases in my
life for this is not party me
this is me in recovery going to bed at
10 o'clock
uh and behaving myself uh so i i was
actually a pretty good choice right then
i was
uh really concerned with sobriety and
really living it very
uh completely and uh you know not like
now
after i after i it stopped snapping at
my heels my hard drug use
i started smoking pot about after about
14 years of being straight
and now i'm definitely pothead hippie
but when i was uh
trying to help her i was completely
straight and
and going to meetings and you know
behaving myself and i
i think we were a good influence